c'est par visioconférence que le
président ivoirien prend la parole
devant l'assemblée générale des nations
unies alors que se profile la
présidentielle fixée au 31 octobre
prochain alassane ouattara adopte un ton
rassurant et assure que le processus
démocratique se poursuit peuple ivoirien
va élire le 31 octobre 2010 son prochain
président de la république en dépit de
la crise sanitaire qui est laconique 19
toutes les dispositions sont prises pour
que cette l'ancien soient apaisées et
transparentes
à l'image de celle de 2015
malgré cette apparente sérénité la
situation politique en côte d'ivoire
reste tendue en cause la décision du
conseil constitutionnel de valider la
candidature d'alassane ouattara un
troisième mandat présidentiel tout en
rejetant celle de ses opposants et
notamment celle de son principal rival
l'ex premier ministre guillaume soro
la juridiction suprême a également
refusé 39 autres des 44 candidatures
présentées pour le scrutin dont celle de
l'ex président ivoirien laurent gbagbo
qui compte encore de nombreux partisans
face à ce qu'ils considèrent comme une
manoeuvre du pouvoir
un autre ancien président ivoirien henri
konan-bédié à lui appelé à la
désobéissance civile
en tenant ce discours
henri konan-bédié a attiré à ses côtés
de nombreux partis d'opposition qui
refusent eux aussi la nouvelle
candidature d'alassane ouattara la
constitution ivoirienne limite en effet
le nombre de mandats présidentiels à
deux mais selon la juridiction suprême
l'entrée en vigueur d'une nouvelle
constitution en 2016 a remis les
compteurs à zéro c'est tension
grandissante dans le pays font planer la
menace d'une nouvelle crise post
électorale meurtrière semblable à celle
de 2010 près de 3000 personnes avaient
perdu la vie lors des affrontements qui
ont suivi le refus de laurent gbagbo de
reconnaître la victoire revendiquée par
son opposant d'alors alassane ouattara